- Whoo, when you have a
sub, it's like a free day.
Your teacher's gone.
They're not gonna know what you did.
Even if they do, they're
not gonna know who it was
'cause the sub doesn't know who you are.
- If a substitute teacher
walks into the classroom
like this and kind of ready for defeat,
they will be eaten alive.
This guy looked like really disheveled.
His tie and buttons were always loose
and hair flying, the
little hair that he had,
was like everywhere.
I was blatantly not paying attention,
and he actually had decided to call me out
in front of the rest of the class.
And I was like, "Oh, sorry,
this is really boring
"and you're not capturing our attention."
And he was like, "Oh, okay,
so you have a lot to say.
"You're a big mouth; come
to the front of the class."
And I was like, "Okay, sounds good."
And he goes, "If you
talk back to me again,
"I'm gonna give you a detention slip."
And I said, "You can't
give me a detention slip.
"You're a substitute teacher.
"I'll just rip it up and
that's it; it'll be fine."
And he goes, "Oh, well
since you're so confident
"about your future, why don't you tell me
"what else is gonna
happen in your future?"
And I went like this over
his head like a crystal.
And I said, "Oh, let me
see what's in my future."
And he was like, "You gotta
get the fuck out of here.
"Go to in-school suspension."
He was so mad that I'd
pointed out the fact
that he was bald.
I had everyone in the class laughing.
When Mr. Sutton, my social
studies full time teacher,
came back, he had asked me what happened.
I told him the whole story.
I could tell that he was
holding back laughter.
And he gave me like an extra detention.
He's like, "That's hysterical,
but you still have detention.
"That's awful."
And I was like, "Okay, fair enough.
"Good, I'm glad you think it's funny,
but I deserve it so cool."
- So he was short, and he
just seemed very nerdy.
We just knew, everybody
was looking at each other,
we knew that something was gonna happen
within that 40 minutes.
We didn't think that we
were really gonna have
any work to do 'cause
usually when subs come
they give you super easy work.
And this teacher was telling us,
"Yeah, here's an assignment
that you're gonna do.
"You need to have it done
by the end of class."
We're like, "We're not doing this."
We were trying to think
of different things
we could come up with.
And my friends were like,
"Brianna, you should
"maybe fake an asthma attack."
And I don't know why I thought this was
gonna be a good idea.
And so what we thought was gonna happen
was I was gonna fake it.
And he was gonna be like,
"Okay, a student's sick.
"Go to the nurse."
But no, he called 911.
I'm in the corner hiding my face
so he can't see what's going on.
Some of my friends came
over to the corner as well,
and they're like, "Okay, just act like
"you're still having
a hard time breathing.
"We'll give you your inhaler."
And so I started calming down.
I was like, "Oh, my God,
I think it's going away.
"I think it was a false alarm."
He's like, "No, you still
need to see the ambulance."
When the ambulance came,
I explained to them.
I was like, "I took my
inhaler, and I think
"I'm just feeling better.
"It's fine."
And they checked on me and everything,
and they're like, "Everything's okay."
Also should mention my dad was
my principal in high school
as well, so none of this was
a smart idea for me to do.
And I knew, and my dad knows
me obviously, I'm his daughter.
He knew I was not having an asthma attack.
- The sub was a very kind of
buttoned-up nerdy looking guy.
So when you're in elementary
school, one of the things
you almost always do is go around reading.
Where one person reads a paragraph
and the next person reads a paragraph.
When we had a sub and
it was my turn to read,
I'd always fake like I
couldn't real very well.
And I could read really
well, but I would pretend
like I couldn't.
And my friends and everyone
else in the class would laugh
knowing that I was faking it.
But the teacher would get mad at them
thinking they were making fun of me.
And so then I would have to pretend like
I was being made fun of.
We kept it going too long,
and I kept laughing too.
And the substitute teacher
finally caught onto it
that I was faking with him
and that I could read well.
And in retrospect, it
was really bad because
there were kids who couldn't read well,
and they probably felt shitty.
- So my brother who is about
two grades older than me
gave me a fart machine.
It was about this big
with a remote control.
And in our class rooms, for some reason,
there was a bathroom
at the back of class .
So on a normal day, you
would here a few things
coming from the bathroom.
But I took the fart
machine in because we knew
we were gonna have a
substitute teacher that day.
And I went into the bathroom and just
let off a few rips.
She was older, definitely
grandma level age.
Yeah, I think she didn't
realize she was coming
to middle school that day.
I think she probably was
expecting an elementary class,
and she was in for a rude awakening.
I did it probably about
three of the fart noises.
They were varied fart noises.
The first two were pretty mild,
but then there was one that
was such an unbelievable fart.
It just kind of went on for awhile.
My classmates sold me out.
When I walked out,
everybody just turned around
and started laughing at me.
And so the teacher asked
if I made any noises
while I was in there.
And I tried to say that it was Mexican
from the night before, but she
saw the bulge in my pocket.
So after I presented it,
she made me push the button
in front of class.
And of course, another fart came out.
The whole class laughed.
She took the fart machine
away and had my mom
come in and get it.
So, that was kind of annoying.
My mom has a great sense of humor anyway
so she kind of loved it.
And I'm pretty sure she
took the fart machine
into work and used it herself.
- Now that I'm an adult, I have friends
that are school teachers,
and I know how hard it is.
So I would say, "Give yourself a break."
- Don't be, I'm not gonna
curse, but a little brat.
Don't be a brat.
- They're just there to take
over for your original teacher.
- Mister Substitute Teacher...
- I don't really remember
your name, but I'm sorry.
- I definitely feel bad about what I did.
- I'm really sorry.
I'm sorry.
- I apologize; I did lie.
I did not in fact have
Mexican food the night before.
- I'm not really sorry.